hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown there's been a
wave of Cova 19 related lawsuits as
health officials continue to battle the
virus Fox News senior judicial analyst
Judge Andrew Napolitano weighs in on
some of these legal disputes and
discusses how they may play out also
special events across the nation have
been cancelled amid the pandemic leaving
many Americans who've shelled out big
bucks for weddings vacations and
concerts wondering if they'll be able to
get their money back
Regina Conway a consumer expert with
shopping platform slick deals shares
insight on how to rebook or get a refund
during these trying times plus
commentary by Abbie hornacek host of the
getting schooled podcast and parked on
Fox Nation the Fox News rundown is a
Daily News podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to FoxNews
podcast.com Brian Kilmeade
I'm Martha McCallum I'm David Asman and
this is the Fox News rundown
Wednesday May 27th 2020 unleash a Brady
no matter what happens with the virus
itself pandemic related court fights
could linger for years to come over a
variety of issues including
constitutional rights the government
cannot willy-nilly interfere with a
fundamental Liberty and the governor
can't make his own laws I'm Dave Anthony
this Korona crisis has altered a lot of
summer travel plans so if you need to
rebook or try to get a refund be
diligent and patient in all cases when
you're dealing with the travel industry
in particular right now it you just
should expect that there will be delays
delays to get through to customer
service delays to get responses and i'm
abby hornacek i've got the final word on
the fox news rundown
[Music]
while the US slowly reopens there have
been hundreds of lawsuits filed across
the country some of them well-publicized
battles pitting state lawmakers against
the governor's accused of overstepping
with stay at home orders those have had
mixed results so far but there are many
other kinds over business shutdowns or
employees not feeling protected enough
or churches not being allowed to open
one of the biggest battles might be over
nursing home care we're encouraged by
the progress that many of the governors
and states have made in their testing of
their population however White House
Task Force member dr. deborah birx had
urged states earlier this month to test
all nursing home residents and staff
over two weeks an Associated Press
review finds at least half of the states
haven't met that window some citing the
manpower and the cost involved New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo has ordered an
investigation of the response and
long-term care facilities but he's been
criticized for ordering homes not to
turn away kovat patients released from
hospitals one of several orders he
eventually reversed Cuomo in turn has
blamed the federal government the CDC
guidance said a nursing home cannot
discriminate against the kovat patient
because at that time the issue was
hospital capacity but angry and
grief-stricken families may demand
accountability for the deadly spread
through a vulnerable population the
government is largely immune from
litigation because it has enacted laws
that make itself immune Judge Andrew
Napolitano is Fox's senior judicial
analyst the only time it is not immune
as if it acts in bad faith meaning if it
was enacting these regulations for a
nefarious purpose not for a lawful
purpose thus the litigation will not be
against government it will be against
those whose behavior government
compelled against nursing homes against
businesses expect a flood of litigation
and a flood of legislation to try an
order the litigation as the politicians
wanted to go
and to try and insulate their friends
from the consequences of their neck
their own negligence when it comes to
the nursing homes about a third of the
deaths nationwide have been in long-term
care facilities but in New York for
instance the governor essentially blamed
the federal government look I was
following CDC guidelines what do you
have to prove that to win a case no he
would know he would just have to prove
that he acted in good faith because he's
the government if if he were a private
nursing home he'd have to prove that he
complied with government regulations but
because he's the governor we're talking
about andrew Cuomo because he's the
governor he enjoys qualified immunity he
qualifies for the immunity by
demonstrating that his behavior was in
good faith and then he is immune the
nursing homes don't have that kind of
qualified immunity unless they can show
that they were forced to behave as they
did by the government so if the
government forces you to do something
against your will and a third person is
harmed by you doing what the government
forced you to do theoretically
theoretically you enjoy the same
immunity as the government now that's
not quite the case with the nursing
homes I mean to me and I've said this on
air already
forcing nursing homes to take the
knowing sick no matter who told them to
do er whose guidelines are being
complied with is utterly insane
nevertheless they did that and innocent
people died both the sick people who
were sent there and they well people who
had been well until the second these are
issues where there's no immunity
involved then the juries will have to
sort out whose fault it was right and
arguably you know I'm sure the attorneys
for these homes and attorneys for the
families will bring into play what the
state of those facilities were before
all of this because advocates for
residents argue there are some
long-standing neglect issues and without
the ability to sue sometimes you know
they would have no recourse but there's
a political article about lobbyists for
the nursing home industry already
gaining some liability protection in at
least 20 states and arguing you know
that they did have to adapt quickly to
new regulations and sometimes didn't
have the protective equipment they need
so already trying to sort of say look we
were just doing what the government told
us to do well much of that so-called
liability see what I'm laughing and what
I call it so-called Lisa is at the hands
of government executive orders none of
which have the force of law so however
well-intended andrew Cuomo of New York
or Phil Murphy of New Jersey maybe they
are not the legislature as far as I know
no legislature in the country not the
Congress and not any of the 50 state
legislatures has enacted legislation
granting immunity retro actively to the
nursing home industry but some
governor's are purported to do so by
their executive orders those executive
orders are not worth the paper that
they're written on well certainly the
nursing home debate and those cases have
a long way to go what about the lawsuits
over churches not being allowed to open
because there have been a number of
those already - and the president has
argued that they should be considered
essential some governor's have deemed to
liquor stores and abortion clinics as
essential but have left our churches and
other houses of worship it's now right
is it constitutional to keep a church
closed it is not constitutional to keep
a house of worship closed for any reason
so when the president says the free
exercise of religion is essential what
he really means is it is constitutional
now it has been interfered with by the
governor's he has said he will override
these gubernatorial decisions he does
not have the
ability to override them but he does
have the ability and he's done this to
his credit to dispatch the Department of
Justice to go into federal court and to
sue governor's that are impairing the
free exercise of religion such a lawsuit
was threatened to the governor of Nevada
and in response to that threat the
governor of California
loosened the screws a little bit you can
have 25 people in a house of worship as
long as they socially distance but you
can't have more than a hundred well
there are Roman Catholic cathedral said
hold 3,000 so where does he come up with
100 he didn't limit manufacturing
facilities to 100 he just said you have
to socially distance so that's the
federal argument the governors are
treating non religious entities
different than they're treating
religious entities basically saying to
the governor of Nevada you know you're
Allah you're about to open up the
casinos why don't you how why are you
treating churches differently well and
the interesting thing is there have also
been lawsuits over businesses that
either opened and they got penalized for
opening too early or haven't been
allowed to open you know along the same
lines do can the governor's actually
based on the fact that there's a public
health emergency order me to stay home
order my business to stay closed tell me
I can't go to church or buy a gun when I
want you well we're about to see two
types of litigation one is the criminal
prosecution of people who were arrested
or summoned for the violation of
gubernatorial guidelines because the
governors are enforcing those guidelines
as if they were criminal statutes the
governors don't have the right to
write their own laws and assign their
own penalties so those criminal
prosecutions will all go away but the
barrage of civil litigation will come
you asked a profound question that's the
governor of New York have the right to
close down your favorite restaurant and
prevent you from going to it the answer
is no the governor doesn't only the
legislature can write laws of that
magnitude and if the legislature did
there'd be constitutional issues as well
your right to travel is a fundamental
Liberty the government cannot
willy-nilly interfere with a fundamental
Liberty and the governor can't make his
own laws justice Neel gore such as
written if the prosecutor could write
his own laws and enforce the laws he has
written then he's not a prosecutor he's
a prince one other thing this holiday
weekend we just had where there were
some big crowns in some popular places
and I'll use Missouri's Lake of the
Ozarks as an example the Health Director
for the state issued a warnings of you
know potential long-term and tragic
consequences because of social media
posts showing a big crowd both in and
around the pool people not wearing masks
too close together if someone who
attended an event like that got sick
with kovat would they have any recourse
or they essentially put themselves at
risk so it's their own fault I don't
know who owns this Lake or who manages
it or who occupies it if some private
entity does there might be recourse
against them they have a difficult time
proving how they contracted the disease
on the other hand Missouri recognizes
something called assumption of the risk
which is if a person is fully aware of
the risk dependent upon certain behavior
and undertakes that behavior anyway then
they can be as much as or even more at
fault than whatever entity allowed the
risk to exist and even if you're going
to some place that's been reopened that
maybe isn't in
forcing social distancing rules for
instance you should follow those rules
because the issue is not in my view Lisa
should we follow the rules the issue is
should the government use the power of
force rather than the power of
persuasion to induce or compel
compliance with the rules the government
has a bully pulpit open and the
government can use that bully pulpit to
educate and even intimidate but a bully
pulpit is not the same thing as using
people with guns and badges to compel
behavior which two weeks ago or two
months ago or six months ago from which
under any plain reading a reading of the
Constitution is perfectly lawful Judge
Andrew Napolitano Fox senior judicial
analyst always a pleasure sir thanks for
your time
all the best Lisa stay well hope we can
chat again soon
[Music]
this is Abbi hornacek with your Fox News
commentary
coming up the u.s. is giving Brazil the
same treatment China and Europe got in
this coronavirus outbreak if they're in
an exponential growth phase like Brazil
is we probably need to stop travel which
is what happened after midnight this
morning restrictions that Republican
congressman Mark Greene told Fox News
makes sense now that Brazil has the
second most Corona cases in the world
behind only us you look at the counts
that are coming to us from Brazil 300
and plus thousand cases 22 thousand
deaths there's a university down there
that predicts that it could be 12 times
that non-us citizens are not allowed to
come here from Brazil or if they've been
in that country the past 14 days those
who have American relatives or green
cards are exempt so anyone with travel
plans has to make changes something
airlines are very used to these days
ever since March a lot of flights have
been canceled which means a lot of
Americans are trying to rebook and get
refunds in all cases when you're dealing
with the travel industry in particular
right now it you just should expect that
there will be delays delays to get
through to customer service delays to
get responses
Regina Conway is an expert in Consumer
Affairs with slick deals nets the
important thing to note is that while
the airlines are very flexible as far as
offering credits for the future they are
probably less inclined to you want to
proactively offer a refund so in that
case you do want to wait until you are
notified or that you see that the flight
that you were supposed to be on is
actually cancelled don't voluntarily
cancel your travel yourself if you're
looking for that money back refund
otherwise you do have a lot of
flexibility to rebook the airlines are
being offering generous you know sort of
waiving their fees and you can book for
travel in the future but if you are
looking for that money back it does need
to come in the form of a cancellation by
the airline what happens if you've
decided you don't want to not only do
not want to go to where you were gonna
go you don't want to plan it sort of six
months later one year later you just
want it to be done the problem with that
is
you don't have a refundable ticket and
the airline itself has not cancelled or
significantly delayed that or
significantly changed that flight that
you were booked on and what constitutes
a significant change varies from airline
to airline you may be in the position
that you do need to take that credit for
a future travel now it doesn't mean that
you necessarily have to go to the same
destination you might be able to apply
that credit to a different flight
entirely however unless that
cancellation is on behalf of the airline
you are likely going to be getting a
credit instead what if you show up and
this has been happening the last couple
weeks what if you show up and there's a
long line and the planes full and you
have somebody sitting in a middle seat
and you don't want to travel because you
don't like the situation that's not you
don't think it's safe what do you do
I think the best-case area there is to
really approach the customer service
representatives in some cases it will
depend who it is that you're speaking
with if you don't like the response that
you're getting immediately you may want
to you know try through the through
calling the Airlines hotline number to
get the customer service support there
overall the airline's you know obviously
everybody is trying to accommodate as
best as they can in this changing
climate and trying to do the best that
they can sometimes you might come up
with somebody who is not as helpful as
you would hope but if you're genuinely
uncomfortable about getting on that
flight you should not be doing that all
right let's move to hotels hotels are
probably not so difficult right hotels
it depends on if you booked through a
third party or if you booked directly
with the hotel I'm hearing in many cases
where someone booked directly in the
hotels are a little bit more inclined
and it also depends on the chain that
you are have booked with for example you
know some have generous cancellation
policies like the Four Seasons is
allowing cancellations up to 24 hours
prior to arrival as long as the changes
made by June 30th of this year others
where you're booking through those
third-party online travel agencies in
some cases it may take more work if the
hotel is closed and you know due to the
government restrictions and they don't
have a service to offer you you are
entitled to you that refund but it will
take some diligence and persistence in
some cases you know you might be better
off if your travel still several months
out you might be better off waiting as
it gets closer to that cycle to see
where things stand what about a vacation
rental like I like if you've done a week
somewhere you have something planned
somewhere in the summertime this is
another one where it varies greatly and
again they're really looking at sort of
that short-term shorter term window
right now
so Airbnb for example has an extenuating
circumstances policy that they have said
will apply under the pandemic right now
and so any experiences or reservations
that were made before March 14th with a
check-in date up to June 30th may be
canceled before check-in without any
sort of cancellation fees or anything
like that however if you are booked
farther out and you want to cancel then
you are subject to whatever the host
cancellation policy would be in that
case similar but with verbo which is
owned by Expedia they are encouraging
refunds for people who from their owners
and managers to issue at least a partial
refund for situations where a flexible
credit can't be accommodated the cruise
industry has shut down
remember the diamond princess back in
February that was a big moment in the
escalation of the corona virus outbreak
more than 500 passengers got infected
you know this is Renee Smith and her
husband Clyde tested positive were taken
off the ship and had to be quarantined
at a Japanese hospital of course no one
prevented that the Smith's never had
symptoms and after testing negative came
back home to Georgia and are taking part
in an antibody study of their blood to
help other corona patients this as all
the cruise lines try to recover dealing
with cancellations Andry bookings many
of the major companies are offering two
options for those who have a cruise
booked during the suspension so either a
full cash refund
or the option to put the value paid
towards the future cruise with some sort
of added incentives in the form of
onboard credits so Carnival Cruise Line
for example has announced that they'll
they'll be starting some of their
cruises on August 1st but if you're not
comfortable starting that early you want
to wait and see how these things are
being handled how the situation is
evolving passengers booked on any voyage
departing before September can postpone
the trip without penalty for up to a
year or you can simply cancel as well
and so you'll want to go to go to the
respective cruise line that you have
booked with if you're still interested
in taking a cruise in the future there
are some good incentives for people to
just take the credit and sort of apply
it toward a future sailing however if
you just want the refund many of them
have that refund request form on their
website if you booked through a travel
agent than you should contact your agent
to help you with that refund process ok
but what if it's not during this current
time and you already have something for
January and you're like I am NOT gonna
go on a cruise ship until there's a
vaccine or whatever reason you don't
want to go because you're still afraid
of the virus will they be flexible with
you on that that will depend on several
factors first of all you may not want to
deal with that right now because they
are likely working on the situation to
resolve current cancellations that are
much closer to sale dates and it may
depend on what type of ticket you booked
what restrictions there are on that
ticket if you have booked with a credit
card you can also check your travel
insurance or if you have travel
insurance through the credit card that
you use to book your travel if that's
something that you need to resort to and
then it's if you did have travel
insurance in general you should check
that policy as well as possible that
Kovan could fall under an exclusion
there but start with that if you're not
making any headway with the cruise lines
directly do you tell people to get
travel insurance all the time or is it
not something that people should do
typically I would say in this day and
age is something that people will
probably look at more closely however
exclusions could apply so you'll want to
get a policy that covers off it's you
know all-encompassing and you really
need to make sure that you
to find prints on that in general if
it's you know basic domestic travel and
it's just a trip that you're taking to
for a few days it may not be worth it
here we are coming into the summer and
weddings lots of weddings I'm certain
have already been either blown up or
postponed in some way or changed in some
way what should people do dealing with
the function hall dealing with hotels
dealing with all the things that they've
already planned right and this is a
planning of the wedding initially it
wasn't you know a lot of work to begin
with now you have the second phase of
work which is trying to figure out
what's going to happen whether you're
planning to postpone your wedding to
later dates or whether you're just
trying to you know maybe your plans have
changed entirely and and you might do
something with smaller and local and
whatever else so the weddings and events
will vary greatly from what your
contracts are from vendors to vendor and
you should you should really first step
is pull all of the contracts that you
signed if you still plan to utilize the
respective vendors at a later date work
with them to fit so accordingly most of
them are trying to be as accommodating
as possible obviously you may not get
the exact case that you're looking for
because they may have already booked
somebody before the pandemic started for
a certain date so there will need to be
some flexibility on both sides if you
obtained event insurance prior to cover
19 this is another one similar to travel
insurance
some people get event insurance for
things like a wedding check your policy
if you're signing up for a policy now
most of the insurance companies are
exempting covered related delays and
cancellations for any new policies but
if you had your policy in place prior to
the crisis you may be eligible for a
refund if you have tickets to a concert
you're probably not going so many shows
are being canceled the other day country
music star John Rich told our Fox News
rundown podcasts touring is not going to
be anything that's going to happen
probably for the rest of years what I'm
hearing and potentially you know into
next year sometime because problem is
how do you socially distance twenty
thousand big and rich fan you can't so
the show must not go on for now most
tickets are booked through I take a
vendor such as Live Nation or ticket
masters
so right now you do need to work
directly through them if an event was
canceled entirely similar to a flight or
a hotel that's not open you are entitled
to get a refund however in many cases
that may take a while it's not something
that's going to show up in your account
immediately they are saying up to 30
days and that's assuming that the event
itself has been cancelled in many cases
this really depends on who the event
organiser is how those refunds are
handled so if an event has been
cancelled you are entitled to get that
refund and potentially you should be
getting it as soon as 30 days however if
an event has been postponed it means
that the event organisers are still
working to determine whether the event
will be rescheduled or cancelled and so
in the meantime your tickets are still
considered to be valid and in that case
you're not going to get that refund but
I am imagining no matter what it is
you're dealing with you have to be
patient right because these people are
overwhelmed probably that's right and
being rude to somebody on the phone is
never a good wait again what you're
looking for if you're trying to get that
refund is the the best way to approach
it is to be understanding and have that
patience and you might even wait that
hour to get to speak to somebody so it
requires patience of everybody but
understand that everyone is trying to do
the best that they can right now
Regina Conway consumer expert with slick
deals thanks so much for joining us
thanks so much for having me
[Music]
it's the latest from fox news podcasts
to campaign with bread pair with updates
from reporters on the trail and in
studio experts spread keeps you informed
on the 20/20 race go to fox news podcast
comm and download the campaign with bret
baier now subscribe to this podcast at
fox news podcasts dot-com it's time for
your fox news commentary what's on your
mind
Top Gun arguably one of the most iconic
releases in cinematic history I'm gonna
throw this fox news commentary back to
1986 because that was the year that one
of the best one of the most iconic and
one of the most quotable movies
premiered now you might have heard
there's a Top Gun two coming out so I
actually had the unique opportunity to
do a special for Fox Nation about what
it takes to become a Top Gun pilot
outside of what's portrayed on the big
screen and let me tell you this training
is no joke
these men and women go through a gamut
of exercises and training to earn their
status as an elite pilot and something I
really want to note about my time
filming this special is this pilots put
their lives on the line every single day
not only in missions but also in their
training every time they fire up that
f-18 and lift off of the runway they're
putting themselves in a position of
danger what happens if something goes
wrong in the air and they have to eject
from the aircraft the sheer vertical
force of the seat leaving the jet is
enough to knock the pilot out then they
land in the ocean what do you do when
you're being dragged down by the weight
of your water logs clothes and parachute
there is so much training that goes into
preparing for these scenarios and that
goes for anyone in the military it's
easy to shift our attention to this
general sense of gratitude for what our
military does for us overseas but before
they leave our soil they're putting in
dangerous work on a daily basis and that
brings me to a day we just observed
holidays remind us of things we often
take for granted Thanksgiving
example that's when we really sit down
and show gratitude for the things in our
lives but that's also something we
should be doing every day on someone's
birthday we shower them with love and
give them our complete attention but
again why don't we do that consistently
I know that's something I definitely
need to work on and the same goes for
Memorial Day we're reminded of the lives
of our heroes taken too soon while
fighting for our freedom
so since Memorial Day has passed I
challenge everyone including myself to
reflect on the selflessness of other
people whether it's our military our
frontline workers during Kovan 19 or
even a loved one without the catalyst of
a holiday i'ma be hornacek
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes